I'm the one that needs to go after her
bring me my horse you've always been the
hero of our story Princess Anna you
showed the people of arendelle what true
love dedication and courage are all
about you're one of those rare heroes
who don't have a bad bone in their body
but at some point in time someone very
close to you was being treated like a
villain so you know better than anyone
that there are two sides to every coin
my sister's not a monster
Queen mal said it herself there's good
and bad in everyone so that means that
even the evilest people can have a
change of heart keep watching as we
reveal the top 10 Disney characters who
are both heroes and villains you won't
believe which peaceful ruler came this
close to the point of no return
Hades Hades may have a wicked pass but
he's managed to be the good guy on more
than a few occasions did you cut your
hair he's the perfect example of a
villainous hero on went and he's selfish
and cruel but on the other hand he's
reasonable and helpful when mogera
offered to sell her soul to Hades in
exchange for her lover soul he obliged
which is exactly why I got a feeling
you're gonna leap at my new offer and in
descendents 3 Hayes agreed to cure
princess Audrey despite having been
locked up for over two decades Merida
princess Merida of dunbroch helps save
her kingdom from mordioux but before she
could become the hero she dreamed of
being Merida had to play the villain
card I want a spell to change my mom
sure she saved her mom her brothers and
her people but she's the one who put
them in danger in the first place if
Merida had never struck a deal with the
old witch her mom and brothers would
never have turned into wild bears but
hey what's in the past is in the past
right Captain Hook Captain Hook may be
the villain in the Disney movie Peter
Pan but he's the hero in the live-action
TV series once upon a time everyone sees
Captain Hook as the bad guy because he
continuously tries to kill Peter Pan but
in reality Peter Pan isn't that nice of
a guy he chopped hooks hand off and fed
it to the crocodile
and he steals children from their window
and brings them to Neverland suddenly
hook doesn't sound half bad
mother Gothel mother Gothel is probably
one of the most despicable Disney
villains of all time but we can't deny
that she kept Rapunzel's safe the
outside world is a dangerous place
despite being the one who kidnapped her
in the first place on more than one
occasion
Gothel has proven that she truly cared
for Rapunzel when she thought Rapunzel
had been kidnapped from her tower she
was legitimately worried about her Simba
Simba from The Lion King is another
perfect example of a hero turned villain
turned hero he was arrogant and boastful
which led to him putting himself in
dangerous situations you can't do
anything to me as a result scar took
advantage of him and Mufasa passed away
Simba then ran with his tail between his
legs he believes that he had killed his
father what you do kid something
terrible so he hid allowing scar to
wreak havoc on Pride Rock but luckily
Simba found his wits and came back to
save the day uma when we were first
introduced to human descendants too we
were led to believe that she was a total
villain but by the time descendants
three came along it became obvious that
she was just misunderstood so we're
saving your precious people and your
behinds uma wanted to free her people
which meant going up against mal and ara
Don uma kidnapped Ben and tried to bring
down the barrier but eventually she
joined forces with her enemies and did
the right thing Gaston there's no use
debating it no one is as slick or quick
as Gaston from the Beauty and the Beast
despite being a pompous villain Gaston
always saw himself as the hero and so
did many of the town's folk while Gaston
had little respect for anyone but
himself he still risked his life to save
Belle sure she didn't want or need his
help he's no monster guest on you are
but just like a hero he gave it to her
anyway
Ariel Princess Ariel was both the hero
and the villain of her movie The Little
Mermaid sure she never intended on
anyone getting hurt but she still put
the entire ocean at risk in exchange for
her very own happiness the only way to
get what you want
is to become a human yourselves
Arielle knew that dealing with the sea
which could be disastrous but she did it
anyway
as a result Ursula got her hands on the
Trident and turned King Triton into a
poor unfortunate soul luckily Ariel and
Eric ended up saving the day mal now
from Disney's descendants is yet another
disney villain who turned out to be a
hero she was born and raised on the Isle
of the lost where people value evil
deeds above all else
Maleficent had big plans for her
daughter who was more than happy to see
them through do I have to remind you
what we're all here for but by the end
of the descendants mal had a change of
heart and chose to be good proving that
she was both a hero and a villain Elsa
Elsa is probably the last person you'd
expect to see on this list but she is
indeed one of the villains of Disney's
frozen Elsa nearly killed her own people
with her ice powers she set off an
internal winter and froze her sister's
heart in the end also realize that
isolating herself wasn't the answer but
it took her a while to get to that
conclusion so there you have it 10
disney characters who are both villains
and heroes who is your favorite disney
villain and do they have a good side to
them sound off in the comments and
that's a wrap subscribe to the things
and give this video a big thumbs up
thanks for watching we'll catch you
later
you